a primary school teacher who lost all
four limbs to sepsis has returned to the
classroom after being fitted with bionic
arms 47 year old kath tragenna had both
her legs amputated below the knee and
her arms amputated below the elbow in
order to prevent the spread of sepsis
she was prescribed prosthetic arm hooks
but later fundraised enough money for 3d
printed bionic arms impressive cath
joining us now hi car
morning kay
good morning tell me the difference that
these limbs have made to you
oh gosh um well they mean everything to
me
um
you know they've allowed me to function
as a mum to carry out household tasks at
home and
you know they've allowed me to get back
in the classroom and that really does
mean everything
yeah tell us what happened to you kath
november 2019 i was feeling slightly
unwell at school and asked to leave
early
um i thought it was flu just flu-like
symptoms rested for the weekend and
phoned 111 on the sunday afternoon they
decided to send an ambulance to my house
and after that i remember very little my
body went into septic shock i suffered
multiple organ failure had multiple
cardiac arrests and and i was in a coma
for about seven weeks
oh my goodness me um how have you coped
psychologically
well i think it's so important to
maintain a positive mindset
um
you know i am a mum i wanted to play a
full and active role as a mum again but
at times that seemed impossible and i
really had to break it down to small
tiny goals hour by hour almost sometimes
and maintain a positive mindset and kind
of celebrate every small win
each day
okay and what did small wins look like
oh it would be flipping the cap on a
tube of toothpaste you know anything
that i just couldn't do the day before
but helped me regain my independence
and tell me what it's like being back at
school now
oh i mean it's wonderful um children are
so welcoming so enthusiastic
and
yeah i mean teaching's a passion for me
and it's just a joy to be back
just looking at pictures of you as we're
chatting um to you um
what else is is left now on your
recovery on on your journey where do you
go next
yeah it's still ongoing i'm back in the
classroom just a few hours a week at the
minute and you know hopefully i can get
the strength to increase that um
and then
yeah more family time perhaps overseas
holidays one day and things that at one
time seemed completely impossible
and what would you say to other people
who find themselves potentially um in a
similar position to you i was reading a
story just in in the newspaper this
morning about a nurse that had lost um
three of her limbs
oh yeah
yeah i mean
talk to people communicate to those
around you i had the most wonderful
support you know from family friends my
workplace
don't be afraid to ask for help um but
really as i said before
you know do take time to celebrate those
small gains and don't think too much
about the future if you kind of do your
physio work hard on a day-to-day basis
then
you can achieve what you want to
amazing good for you kath it's great to
talk to you what an inspiration you are
thank you very much
all right thank you kay bye